[Música]
el cerebro humano es asombroso es capaz
de crear herramientas que te permiten
estar aquí en málaga dando esta charla y
que tú me estáis viendo en tiempo real
en cualquier lugar del mundo es capaz de
lanzar con éxito satélites al espacio
con una fina tecnología y también de
hacer microcirugías neurológicas o
cardíacas que les pueden salvar la vida
a una persona
parecería que con toda esta capacidad
nos podría ayudar a resolver cualquier
problema y que nos haría inmensamente
felices pues bien lo que os vengo a
contar hoy es que este cerebro es
también el responsable de nuestro
malestar más profundo
es el que crea y mantiene muchas de las
enfermedades mentales y también el
responsable de nuestro sufrimiento más
intenso y está porque ocurre pues por
diferentes características que tenemos
los seres humanos la primera es cómo
está estructurada en nuestro cerebro
mucho antes de que la evolución llegase
esa corteza de verdad que como se llama
el cerebro inteligente de los seres
humanos estaban allí muy bien asentadas
otras dos estudio ricas la primera es el
sistema es sensible raquídeo que
compartimos con los reptiles
y también es más importante el que más
le interesa el sistema límbico del
cerebro emocional que compartimos con
los mamíferos y porque me interesa tanto
porque el cerebro emocional es el
responsable de nuestra supervivencia es
el garante de nuestra supervivencia
cuando hay algún estímulo en nuestro
alrededor que supone una amenaza
este sistema emocional reacciona
rapidísimamente en eso que comúnmente
llamamos una red está de estrés la otra
característica fundamental es que tal y
como está estructurada centro sistema
límbico le llega la información de
cualquier estímulo externo o interno
el segundo antes de lo que llega a
nuestro cerebro racional medio segundo
en términos cerebrales es un mundo yo
creo que cualquier piloto de fórmula uno
de motoclismo simón está por ganar medio
segundo en una vuelta después bien
grande en nuestro entorno hay una
amenaza mucho antes de que nosotros
podemos responder racionalmente nuestro
sistema límbico medio segundo antes ya
tiene la información y ya ha dado su
respuesta y es fundamentalmente así
y centrada en una respuesta física los
peligros que había cuando el cerebro
emocional se gestó hace millones de años
eran peligros de vida muerte eran
peligros físicos claro el problema es
que la mayoría de los retos que nosotros
afrontamos en nuestro día a día no son
peligros a los que tengamos que
responder físicamente sino son peligros
a los que tenemos que responder social
emocional y sobre todo inteligentemente
otra de las características del ser
humano es que es uno de los animales que
nacen más vulnerables y más dependientes
de un adulto para su supervivencia si a
un bebé oa un niño lo dejamos solo lo
que ocurre es que inevitablemente se
muere la naturaleza es muy consciente de
esto y adoptarlas los bebés y una
capacidad para llorar de manera tan
eficaz quien no hay un adulto que
soporte oí llorar a un bebé sin
prestarle atención aunque a veces lo que
realmente nos dan ganas es de tirarlo
por la ventana sabiendo qué es lo que
hace que un ser tan vulnerable pueda
sobrevivir por lo que los psicólogos
llamamos la leche con amor la leche
garantiza nuestra supervivencia
biológica la supervivencia en nuestro
cuerpo el amor que va acompañado a esa
leche es la que le garantiza al bebé que
va a ver un adulto que le va a cuidar
que le va a proteger que le va a
defender que debe alimentar que le va a
dar todas las necesidades básicas el
psicólogo clínico roberto aguado en su
terapia de interacción recíproca para mí
los modelos más lúcidos a la hora de
entender la enfermedad mental y su
tratamiento nos explica 69 deseos
básicos que todo niño debe satisfacer
para sentirse seguro
pero claro siendo niños en un mundo tan
complejo siendo tan vulnerables es muy
difícil que en algún momento nos
sintamos alguna carencia y cuando
sentimos alguna carencia qué pasa
pues que si somos demasiado pequeños
logrado notorios llorar y confiar no
conscientemente doblemente en que algún
adulto venga a salvarnos ya rescatarnos
pero qué pasa si nuestro cerebro
inteligente ya se está desarrollando
pues que el cerebro inteligente buscará
soluciones para volvernos a nuestro
equilibrio ya nuestra seguridad
por ejemplo mi madre era profesora de
infantil de niños de 5 años supongo que
algún día o que muchas vidas no tenía
con quién dejar me así que me llevaba
con ella al colegio y me dejaba en la
clase de su amiga anna la clase de al
lado yo recuerdo no se si recuerdo decir
a nao luego o lo he oído después quien a
veces le decía a mi madre es increíble
su hijo tiene 3 años y es capaz de
seguir la clase de los de 5 con total
normalidad os imaginéis como haría
sentiros a mi madre pues supongo que les
eliminaría la cara llena de orgullo y de
satisfacción claro ese niño inseguro que
había sido separado de mamá que estaba
al lado de niños que seguramente eran
más grandes y tenían más capacidades que
el cómo se sintió cuando vio esa cara de
satisfacción de su mamá pues grabó en
ese cerebro profundo en su sistema
límbico que si él era capaz de hacer las
cosas bien era capaz de brillar y
destacar y de estar a la altura su mamá
se sentiría satisfecha lo amaría y su
supervivencia estaría garantizada
tengo la suerte de haber tenido unos
padres excepcionales llenos de amor y
que se han entregado absolutamente por
nosotros que una cosa es la realidad y
otra cosa es lo que nuestro cerebro
percibe así que ese niño inseguro un día
grabó en su cerebro más básico que si
satisfacía el otro conseguía dar la
talla y hacía las cosas bien su
supervivencia estaría garantizada en
resumen primero tenemos a un niño muy
inseguro en un mundo muy complejo y muy
vulnerable que necesita satisfacer a un
adulto necesita de la protección de un
adulto de un adulto para sobrevivir
segundo en su experiencia de repente un
día descubre que haciendo las cosas bien
o haciendo lo que se espera de él
consigue la satisfacción de ese adulto
que le puede proteger
3 cada vez bueno eso se graba en en una
parte del cerebro muy básica en el
sistema límbico con una emoción y con
una sustancia la emoción es la alegría y
la sustancia es un neurotransmisor que
se llama dopamina para qué sirve la
dopamina para qué sirve la alegría para
pegarnos un chute que nos haga sentir
también en nuestro cerebro busque
repetir una y otra vez eso que le ha
funcionado para sobrevivir así que con
esa grabación yo tenía la solución si
cada vez que me siento inseguro consigue
satisfacer a los demás consigo brillar y
consigo hacer las cosas bien mi
seguridad estará garantizada por cierto
voy bien os está gustando porque me la
estoy jugando a decir que es un portador
bueno pero esto ahora no es tan
importante para mí porque he descubierto
que mi seguridad y mi amor no dependen
antes de mis éxitos como de mis fracasos
ahí en mis fracasos es donde he
aprendido a amarme es donde he aprendido
que valgo más de lo que hago
incluso ahí se me ha caído el velo he
descubierto que las personas que me aman
de verdad no me aman solo cuando hago
las cosas bien si no son las que han
estado ahí cuando yo he hecho los
comportamientos más desastrosos y de los
que cientos mayor vergüenza
os fijáis en todo el tiempo que
empleamos intentando quedar bien y
satisfacer a los demás cuando en
realidad la persona y las personas que
más nos aman son justo las que nos han
visto hacer las cosas más desastrosas
las que nos han visto ser desagradables
injustos intolerantes etcétera etcétera
y cuarto el cuarto factor
[Música]
si yo os defiendo a hacer las cosas bien
para sentirme seguro qué pasa si fallo y
claro en cualquier situación podemos
hallar así que tengo una espada de
damocles sobre mi cabeza permanentemente
digo esclavo de eso que un día fue la
solución lo que mi cerebro encontró como
solución para mi seguridad que es
brillar satisfacer a los demás y hacer
las cosas bien se convirtió justo en mi
mayor problema que es mi esclavitud la
opinión y la mirada de los demás y para
eso también desarrollé otra estrategia
básica que era juzgarme salvajemente
para nunca cometer ningún error
eso me garantizaría la supervivencia
pero eso lo que ha provocado es mi mayor
infelicidad
mi mayor esclavitud bueno y como salimos
de este embrollo pues lo que yo os
propongo son las cinco desde el cambio
la primera hace es la consciencia
obviamente sólo podemos ser solo podemos
cambiar algo cuando somos conscientes de
que va mal
de hecho la vida siempre te propone dos
caminos el primero es ese automático que
repetimos y una y otra vez de manera
consciente hacer siempre lo mismo de
hecho mucha gente dice defensivamente es
que yo soy así y cuando alguien me dice
estudios y las y yo le pregunto y eso te
hace sentir bien eso te satisface algo
que normalmente la persona me dice no no
todo contrario mates de emtusa tal y
entonces cómo podemos ser algo que no te
hace sentir mal por eso por definición
nuestra esencia tiene que ser algo con
lo que nos sentimos cómodos tiene que
ser algo con lo que nos sintamos bien
así que yo soy de los que piensa que
somos mucho más eso que nos gustaría
hacer y lo que estamos a descenso lo que
hacemos a veces con esos mecanismos de
defensa que sacamos desde el miedo
el segundo camino el que michael scott
tech llamada el camino menos transitado
es ese en el que podemos decidir que a
partir de hoy voy a vivir mi vida
comprometido con ser coherente con mis
valores
de hecho la vida se puede vivir de dos
maneras vivirla desde tus miedos o
vivirla desde sus valores desde tus
valores y os aseguro que hay una gran
diferencia entre ambos caminos
la segunda fe es el coraje
hay que ser muy valiente para soltar y
deshacerse de todas esas defensas que
hemos ido elaborando durante tantos años
y yo tengo 48 pero mi sistema límbico
vive en presente como el de todos
vosotros el que tienes pasado presente y
futuro es el es el cerebro racional es
la corteza cerebral así que cuando yo
estoy en una situación como ésta en la
que que salga bien o que se haga mal es
un reto mi sistema límbico medio segundo
antes de que ellos pueda ser inteligente
y decir bueno tampoco pasa nada si fallo
va a lanzar un mensaje de peligro que me
va a poner en absoluta tensión ya no soy
el hombre de 48 años soy el niño de 3
asustado independiente de los demás
todos nosotros tenemos ese niño asustado
dentro pero también tenemos un adulto
con plenas capacidades para cuidar un
niño estoy convencido que si saliéramos
a la calle y hubiese un niño que se ha
perdido y que se siente muy asustado
todos tendríamos capacidad para darle
seguridad para darle consuelo y para
ayudarle en la tercera fe es el cariño
que es lo que sostiene ese coraje y esa
valentía pues el amor si nos tratamos
bien a nosotros mismos si nos tratamos a
nosotros como trataríamos con el mismo
cariño que trataríamos a ese niño que
nos vamos a encontrar en la calle seguro
sentiríamos mucha más fuerza y lucha más
poder para afrontar esos miedos que la
vida nos pone delante la flor café es la
constancia hemos trabajado y hemos
repetido ciertos comportamientos durante
años así que eso ha grabado vías
neuronales muy profundas conexiones
neuronales muy profundas que obviamente
no podemos cambiar solo por hacer las
cosas bien un par de veces necesitamos
repetir y repetir y repetir eso de ser
coherente con nuestros valores y la
quinta fe es el corazón
cuando callamos los pensamientos de la
mente fijaros los pensá en cimientos
igual no es casualidad que lo llamemos
así igual es que muchas de las cosas que
nos dicen nuestra mente son realmente
mentiras cuando callamos los
pensamientos de la mente entonces se
abre un espacio de silencio en el que
podemos oír el susurro del corazón y no
me refiero el corazón de manera
romántica ni al corazón como órgano que
es capaz de mandar sangre a todas
nuestras células o incluso generar
a esa seguridad que le da nuestro cuerpo
cada latido me refiero a lo que los
japoneses llaman kokoro que es que ahora
sabemos científicamente gracias a las
investigaciones sobre todo el alma
institute que en cada latido del corazón
hay un impulso electromagnético que está
lleno de información información que
manda a todas nuestras células e
información que también compartimos con
los demás que están dentro de ese campo
energético que genera el corazón en cada
latido pues bien si nosotros nos
conectamos con el corazón estamos
conectados con nuestra esencia de hecho
cuando yo digo yo soy antonio donde me
señaló yo digo yo soy antonio no digo yo
soy antonio y me señaló la mente así que
estoy seguro de que en muy pocos años en
briones años los científicos ya nos
dirán que la inteligencia del corazón es
mucho mayor que la inteligencia de la
mente así que ahora os invito a que os
toméis el pulso aquí en la arteria
realidad es lo más lo más fácil tomaros
el pulso y conectar con ese latido
conectar con vuestra esencia
silencia tu mente escucha tu corazón y
también escucha tu cuerpo donde reside
ese niño asustado que está dentro de ti
conecta con tu corazón y repite
interiormente mi amor es más fuerte que
mi miedo
a partir de hoy veamos simplemente por
ser porque soy una expresión única y
valiosa de la vida
ojalá
deje de vivir anclado en las memorias
del pasado y seas consciente de tu
grandeza ojalá de verdad tu amor sea más
grande que tu miedo y te regales una
vida de amor y de gozo no mereces menos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]